[Musica]
buonasera i miei capelli bianchi fanno
chiaramente capire che ho una lunga vita
e una lunga vita di lavoro come già è
stato anticipato io sono purtroppo
finita nel mondo l'industriale a seguito
della morte di mio papà e mio fratello
in un incidente d'auto è stata una
grossa tragedia che ha colpito la nostra
famiglia che ha colpito l'azienda li
aveva 21 anni non ero mai entrata
fisicamente nell'azienda perché in una
famiglia tradizionale con un maschio
cinque anni più grande della femmina il
maschio faceva l'imprenditore la femmina
alla casalinga e quindi tutto questo mi
ha portato a trovarmi in una situazione
estremamente particolare ed estremamente
difficile però mi sono ritrovata ad
essere punto di riferimento per tutte
quelle persone che avevano dei legami
stretti con mio papà è che un mio
fratello i dipendenti gli amici i buoni
conoscenti e tutti cercavano un
riferimento per questo vuoto che si era
creato attorno a loro
mi sono resa conto di quanto fosse
importante colmare questo vuoto non
avevo la forza non potevo farlo anche
perché non avrebbe il tempo e mi è
venuta in mente l'idea di una fondazione
una fondazione che potesse essere un
punto di riferimento per le persone che
avevano bisogno di trovare un qualche
cosa che riempisse i vuoti che si
sentivano l'idea della fondazione mi è
rimasto nel cuore per moltissimi anni
finché nel 2008 sulla spinta di mia
figlia non aveva molte volte sentito
parlare siamo partite siamo partite
fondazione compie proprio oggi il suo
undicesimo anno è stata un'esperienza
meravigliosa
siamo partiti dal nulla e non fabbricato
che era fatiscente un castello semi
abbandonato
abbiamo lavorato come delle pazze siamo
partite con una mostra su un pittore che
nel castello era vissuto ed all'arte che
ha passati alla musica siamo passati a
risanare il parco che era anche lui in
una situazione orribile e soprattutto
accanto quel sinistra tive si è
sviluppato un fortissimo lavoro con le
scuole e tutti i tipi da zero anni fino
all'università e con alcuni tipi di
malattie abbiamo noi è un collegamento
molto stretto con l'ente che si occupa
dei malati di sclerosi multipla e dei
malati di alzheimer
quindi una gamma molto ampia in questa
nostra attività che si è concretizzata
in questi nove anni e che continua ogni
giorno ad avere delle idee nuove e
pensare di sviluppare qualche cosa di
nuovo ma perché tutto questo perché
probabilmente nel mio cuore che aveva
maturato per tanti anni il desiderio
della fondazione c'era comunque una
grossa esperienza imprenditoriale nel
desiderio di portare l'esperienza
imprenditoriale nel mondo della cultura
grossa esperienza imprenditoriale perché
alla morte di papà di mio fratello
io non sapevo veramente che cosa fare a
21 anni nel 1960 era follia immaginare
che una giovane ragazza potesse entrare
in un settore industriale e soprattutto
meccanico
un giorno ero seduto alla scrivania di
mio fratello che cercava di capire delle
carte incomprensibili sento bussare alla
porta entra un operaio che mi dice
signorina abbiamo bisogno di lei
sbalordita rispondo ma come sapete che
non so fare niente sapete che non sono
mai entrata qui dentro prima d'ora
altrettanto veloce la risposta lo
sappiamo ma noi abbiamo bisogno di lei
siamo sicuri che lei potrà fare bene e
noi se lei vorrà l'aiuteremo mi commuovo
ancora adesso è stata un'esperienza
incredibile
l'azienda della 90 dipendenti era nota
sul mercato per la sua qualità e per la
sua correttezza aveva bisogno di me mi
sembrava veramente impossibile mentre
ancora rimuginavo queste parole si
arriva il capo officina che mi dice
signorina bisogna fare in fretta bisogna
perché ne prende una decisione veloce
perché fuori della porta c'è un signore
che si spaccia della concorrenza che
dice a tutti che questa azienda è finita
e che devono andarsene gli operai andare
a lavorare altrove
era veramente il segnale massimo nel
giro di pochi minuti preso carta e
matita e ho cominciato a scrivere una
lettera ai miei operai in cui dicevo che
forte del loro aiuto porte della loro
collaborazione della loro offerta di
essere miei maestri decidevo di prendere
il posto di mio papà e mio fratello
un'esperienza incredibile difficilissima
era difficile farsi accettare
era difficile fare bene
il primo anno l'ho passato in officina
ho imparato a leggere disegni comperato
funzionamento delle macchine le esigenze
dei clienti come soddisfarle enel in
quel momento veniva spesso alla mente
un momento particolare della mia vita io
sono maestra facevo la terza magistrale
corner o cavallo tutti i giorni mi
allenavo il sabato la domenica andavo i
concorsi la mia insegnante di latino non
era niente contenta di questa mia
attività extra scolastica che secondo
lei mi toglieva concentrazione e alla
fine dell'anno è rimandato di latino io
sono arrivata a casa in lacrime perché
trovavo che non era giusto questo
giudizio confrontando anche i giudizi di
miei compagni e arrivando a casa sfogo
su mio papà cui preleva un bene immenso
il mio dispiacere mi risponde ma se tu
fossi stata da otto non l'avrebbe potuto
fare era la lezione più importante della
mia vita
mentre lavoravo come miei operai in
tutte le difficoltà che avevo nel farmi
accettare mi rendevo conto che bisognava
essere da 8 e forse anche un po più che
di 8 e quindi abbiamo creato questa
collaborazione stupenda pinerolo dove io
vivo è una città dove c'è l'azienda è
una cittadina contornata dalla campagna
allora molto di più
inoltre operai erano quasi tutti i
contadini
loro dovevano vivere la loro vita di
fabbrica ma non isolarsi della loro vita
grave
devono continuare a tenere la loro
cascinotto loro un piccolo podere
dovevano essere allora sempre nelle
stesse persone aggiungendo il lavoro di
fabbrica
e vero avevamo l'assenteismo da gara non
avevamo la sentissimo dal fieno però
comunque andava bene allo stesso gis
organizzata che lo si sapeva
l'importante è avere un'azienda che
fosse veramente il cuore in cui tutti si
sentivano importanti si sentivano
considerati è una delle nostre
innovazioni prima azienda in italia è
stata quella di fare i turni 6 per sé
cioè sei giorni alla settimana e sei ore
per turno con il sole va dire che tutti
potevano dormire nel loro letto perché
dalle donne 24 6
non c'era lavoro c'era lavoro soltanto
nei momenti di grandissima richiesta e
quindi si aggiungeva un turno era
un'innovazione molto grande e una di
quelle innovazioni che hanno fatto di
noi un'azienda all'avanguardia
naturalmente essere imprenditrice in
quegli anni non era facile che cosa
voleva dire contrarsi con delle persone
che non volevano nel modo più assoluto
una donna come interlocutore io ricordo
ad un certo punto eravamo in contatto
con pomigliano d'arco per diventare il
fornitore di primo pagamento
dell'alfasud c'era un desiderio di
qualche cosa che purtroppo è molto
comune in italia e che io avevo escluso
nel modo più assoluto che ho sempre
escluso nel merito di lavoro e quindi
improvvisamente alle cinque del
pomeriggio
succederà qualcosa per cui si fermavano
produzione e allora col mio capo
officina le 7 partivamo con i panini e
il caffè alle 8 del mattino entravamo
pomigliano d'arco non è una cosa
semplice io ero alla guida perché lui
fosse fresco e riposato per la
discussione del giorno dopo e la fine
siamo riusciti a vincere
la battaglia perché hanno visto che
l'auto che dava tutti questi problemi
era un auto sabotata per fare per
apparire dannoso il nostro particolare
tutto questo naturalmente come donna
come ragazza ma credo che l'epilogo di
tutto questo sia stato l'incontro con un
direttore degli acquisti di una grande
azienda di torino che mi aveva dato
appuntamento dovevo proporgli un
particolare una soluzione che noi
avevamo trovato eravamo già fornitori e
avevamo fatto un innovazione arrivò
terzo piano si aprono le porte
dell'ascensore l'usciere mi diceva bene
chiamò subito l'ingegnere l'ingegnere
esce dal suo ufficio e dice agli uscieri
perché ci riuscite
si siede alla scrivania degli uscieri
mettere i piedi sul tavolo e si
sprofonda nella sedia
io seduto di fronte a vedevo soltanto la
suola delle scarpe e quattro peli
bianchi che uscivano dalla punta delle
scarpe è certo un momento terribile però
alle mie spalle la responsabilità di dei
miei operai che diventavano sempre più
numerosi e quindi non potevo permettere
ad altri di trattarmi male mandando il
terzo tempo doveva essere sorridente
sicura con piacevole e quindi ho fatto
tutto la mia chiacchierata tutta la mia
spiegazione tecnica e poi certo punto
doveva aprire il disegno come fare per
questo disegno mi sono alzata di scatto
e lì ero da dieci non più le 8 le o
spalancato il disegno sulle ginocchia
ci siamo incrociati nello sguardo e lui
ha sfilato poco poco poco le gambe e ha
detto soluzione interesse
gli antichi subito i responsabili della
tecnica ed è scomparso per quel giorno
non l'ho visto più
ma è stato l'inizio di una
collaborazione molto molto stretta una
collaborazione che mi ha portato ad
andare a molte volte ogni volta ricevuta
come una principessa e quando questo
signore andato in pensione mi ha mandato
una bella lettera ringraziandomi per il
coraggio la competenza quindi credo un
contributo al lavoro delle donne che in
quegli anni era così poco valutato
grazie
[Applauso]